we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's a
voicemail from an eighteen year old girl
who i converted
out of conservatism take a listen hey
I'm calling from Corpus Christi I meet
he has been watching this show for two
months now I grew up really Republican
and I just everything Trump started you
know his campaign back in 2016 I was
like where is any of the logic and this
anymore and people seem to just blindly
follow him I found your channel a couple
months ago and I haven't watched every
sense and you proved to be an amazing
role model for me I don't how logical
you are how calm you are and you don't
get fired up stopping and it reminds me
that there is still some rationality in
this world and I've dad used I've used a
lot of the things you taught me to be
able to educate others so you are making
a difference in this consideration I
just wanna let you know and wow what an
inspirational message I mean seriously
it is great that that's the stuff that I
love to hear because listen I get
thousands of negative messages a day
most of them based on either my hair or
my ethnicity or my national origin at
homonyms of all different kinds but that
is exactly why this show exists and it's
also why by the way when you say you
what you're doing David is good enough
to support financially with a membership
that's exactly what we are funding we
are funding reaching people who aren't
in positions to pay for programs like
this but who are actually having their
lives changed the direction of that
person of this great young girl has now
been changed as a result of progressive
independent media from a life of
trumpism I mean come on
to a life of logic and reason and
thinking critically we've got a great
bonus show for you today become a member
you'll be helping people like that great
caller we just heard from annual get
access to extra content like the bonus
show